with taskmasters set to step into the
upcoming Black Widow movie it's time to
dive into a long history that's strange
even by the standards of the Marvel
Universe from a school for supervillains
to the South American village populated
by Hitler clones here's the truth behind
the taskmaster the taskmaster made his
first appearance in 1980s Avengers
number 195 arriving on the last page to
set up his full appearance in the next
issue created by David michaleen II and
Jorge Perez his entire identity was
built around one simple idea anything
you can do he can do just like you can
the taskmasters power is usually
referred to as photographic reflexes
which is a fancy way of saying that if
he see someone doing something he can
replicate that action exactly and he
keeps that skill for the rest of his
life that would be a pretty impressive
ability in the real world but taskmaster
lives in the Marvel Universe he can
settle in with some footage of
spider-man or black panther and hop off
the couch a few hours later with the
ability to perfectly replicate their
movements of course there's one
interesting limit to all this
photographic reflexes are taskmasters
only power that means that while he can
watch Captain America throwing his
shield or iron fists doing kungfu he can
only replicate the movements he doesn't
have the Super Soldier Serum enhanced
strength behind the throw or the ability
to channel the power of an immortal
dragon into his hand the same goes for
more mundane abilities too while he can
spend all day watching Wolverine he is
never going to have an adamantium coated
skeleton still he's come away from his
battles against the Avengers with some
pretty impressive abilities well he's
done his share of hands-on villainy the
taskmasters true calling has always been
education of course taskmasters version
of education isn't all that selfless
especially when you consider that his
school the taskmaster Academy is less of
a learning institution and more of a
for-profit training center for henchmen
for a low price
taskmaster takes on classes of aspiring
supervillains and teaches them how to
not only fight like superheroes but more
importantly how to fight
against them there's no better way to
prepare for fighting Captain America
than by training with a guy who can
fight exactly like Captain America while
this mostly functions as a pretty
amazing explanation for where all the
masked members of Hydra and aim get the
confidence to try to punch out Iron Man
or whomever it's worth noting that it's
not just the bad guys who've taken
advantage of taskmaster skills
taskmaster was also responsible for
training John Walker better known as US
agent during the latter's brief stint as
Captain America and for training
government superhero recruits and
Avengers the initiative working really
hard I need results class dismissed
like Deadpool the taskmaster made his
living as a super-powered mercenary for
hire when he wasn't running henchmen
classes meaning that the two characters
ran in pretty similar circles while
their first encounter didn't exactly end
on the best of terms they'd end up
encountering each other pretty often and
that eventually led to a friendship one
of the taskmasters most prominent roles
in the comics came when he was a member
of Deadpool supporting cast his frequent
appearances were mostly due to the fact
that Deadpool hired taskmasters
ex-girlfriend sandy Brandenburg to be
his secretary
but when Deadpool blew up lost his
memory changed his codename to agent X
and was then revealed to have not been
Deadpool all along
taskmaster helped to retrain him as an
assassin and later fought alongside him
in more recent years the two mercenaries
have had a more back-and-forth frenemy
relationship vacation away come to blows
while on opposite sides of a conflict
the Deadpool was also willing to help
taskmaster out by going easy on him in a
fight
so the taskmaster could still get paid
he even invited taskmaster to his
bachelor party
taskmaster status as a sort of utility
player of the supervillain world has led
to more than a few minor roles and
projects outside of comics the most
prominent one at least until Black Widow
hits theaters in 2020 has been his
presence in 2018 spider-man for
PlayStation 4 in the game the taskmaster
occasionally shows up to challenge
spider-man but he does so in a way that
suits how his character works in the
comics
rather than confronting him directly at
first taskmaster put Spidey through a
series of challenges presumably he does
this so that he can get a good look at
Spidey in battle which leads to a fight
where he actually does show up doing a
pretty passable impression of
spider-man's own moves if you know my
moves you know I'm gonna wreck you
surprise me
[Music]
while he's mostly shown up as a villain
or a supporting character the taskmaster
has dabbled and being a protagonist in
his own right thanks to two self-titled
miniseries the first is a relatively
straightforward action-adventure but his
second miniseries is full-on bananas the
main premise is that the taskmaster
ironically enough has a memory problem
his brain is so loaded up with a
superhero moves that his muscle memory
has overwritten other less important
things like his past in order to keep
himself centered he has to keep tracking
down his own memories following his
history so that he can piece it together
and figure out who he is it's sort of
like memento only a million times
weirder the path to taskmasters memories
leads him through things like an
encounter with Dawn of the Dead a Latin
American drug dealer who turns out to be
a white American SHIELD agent who taken
the dawn of the dead identity after
taskmaster trained him that however
pales in comparison to where that series
ends Babelsberg to a small town in the
Bolivian Andes where Nazi scientists
escaped - after World War Two in order
to continue their experiments cloning
Hitler the most successful result was
the longtime Marvel villain the hate
monger but the scientists wound up with
a gigantic stockpile of cloned Hitler
brains which leaked to the Fuehrer's
biochemical essence into the local water
supply the results every man woman and
child in the town essentially has
Hitler's brain leading to a constant
warfare among themselves for control of
the town beyond Babelsberg - and the
dawn of the dead.the big review of the
taskmaster series is that it finally
gives us the taskmasters origin and his
real name that was what he'd forgotten
the piece of knowledge that sent him on
that bizarre quest and the answers
change almost everything for years the
Master has been getting his orders from
a secret organization called the org but
as it turns out the org doesn't exist
instead it's the wife that taskmaster
doesn't remember having Mercedes Merced
who was also his partner back when he
was a SHIELD agent named Tony masters as
Nick Fury tells Steve Rodgers the
taskmaster has been a good guy all along
he just doesn't remember it as masters
he was sent to infiltrate the
supervillain community for shield using
his powers and creating the taskmaster
identity as his cover unfortunately
thanks to a flawed prototype of the
Super Soldier Serum that expanded his
powers all of those skills he'd absorbed
overwrote the personal parts of his
memory
Mercedes has been minimizing the damage
for years by creating the word acting as
taskmasters handler and pointing him in
the right directions for shield of
course once he discovers all this he
immediately has to absorb yet another
sequence of physical actions forgetting
the revelations about Tony masters and
putting a heartbroken Mercedes right
back into the role of working with a
husband who doesn't remember she exists
while it's doubtful that the dawn of the
dead or the taskmaster Academy's
acclaimed henchmen resource program will
make it into the MCU it's not difficult
to imagine how task masters presence
could be felt in the upcoming Black
Widow movie most of Natasha Romanovs
history has to do with her training in
the Red Room a secret Soviet program
designed to create a series of highly
trained agents who are given the
codename of Black Widow in addition to
being briefly shown in Avengers age of
Ultron the Red Room also produced Peggy
Carter's nemesis Dottie Underwood on the
agent Carter TV show with the
taskmasters history of training
supervillains and his ability to serve
as the perfect teacher in virtually any
style of combat it's easy to picture him
as one of Natasha's trainers even more
than the visual the Black Widow version
of the taskmaster captures the
characters signature abilities with an
accuracy that's really exciting both for
longtime comics readers and the MCU fans
who have never picked up a comic in
their lives moviegoers have seen these
characters in action for over a decade
and whether they realize it or not
they've seen how those movies
distinguish their characters and ways
that go beyond their costumes
Captain America Black Panther and the
Winter Soldier for instance all
essentially have the same set of
superpowers but they each have a
fighting style that doesn't look like
the others you're not going to see Black
Panther deliver that one sternum
shattering wait I cake like cap does and
you're not going to see Bucky Barnes
pull off the same acrobatic attacks that
two chala busts out either you will
however see the taskmaster do it all in
the Black Widow trailer alone we see him
perfectly mimicking Captain America
throwing his shield hawk eyes draw with
his bow and Black Panthers claws among
other moves
what's more Black Widow seems to be
making an effort to not just copy the
style but to mimic specific moments from
earlier films the shot with his claws in
particular bears a striking resemblance
to a shot from the worst sequence and
Avengers infinity war much like the way
that the comic-book taskmaster ran his
school for aspiring supervillains the
cinematic version has also embraced his
calling as a teacher this time he's the
guy running the Red Room the top-secret
Russian training facility that produces
the super spies of the Black Widow
program as a result he's someone that
are most familiar Black Widow Natasha
Romanov knows from her past he's also
apparently responsible for training
Yelena Bulova the second Black Widow in
the comics who initially set out to
eliminate and replace Natasha long after
the originals defection to shield the
fact that it's the taskmaster however
adds another layer to the story of Black
Widow returning to the Red Room with the
intention of taking it down not only
just the taskmasters ability to
replicate any movement that he sees make
him the perfect combat instructor it
also hints at something that might just
be the true purpose of the modern MCU
Red Room outside of a brief
hallucinatory flashback in Avengers age
of Ultron we never really see much of
what Natasha's training was like in the
MCU and what we do see seems like some
pretty standard stuff the fact that
taskmaster can fight like the Avengers
though might just mean that this
resurrected Red Room isn't just training
its soldiers to take on enemy spies in
the comics the thing that makes training
with the task masters such an alluring
prospect is that if you're sparring with
a guy who fights exactly like Captain
America then you might just figure out
how to beat Captain America
that sounds like a long shot consider
that cap and the Winter Soldier the
product of a similar red room adjacent
program lead a beatdown on Ironman that
was about as devastating as the one that
hosted if the Red Room is turning out
soldiers designed specifically to take
down superheroes then there's a very
good reason why Natasha would want to
take them down that goes well beyond
revenge and atoning for her own dark
past we'll just have to wait and see if
the task student can defeat the
taskmaster looking round Romanoff the
world will remember this day the day
their hero's failed them
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bells so you don't miss a single one
[Music]